>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washington D.C.
>> Jessica Flynn: Kaitlyn
Greenidge's complex
and gripping debut novel, "We
Love You, Charlie Freeman,"
follows the story of an African
American family, the Freemans,
as they uproot their lives and
move to a research facility
in a largely white
part of the Berkshires.
The Freemans are fluent in sign
language, and they've been hired
to live with a chimpanzee named
Charlie to raise him as a member
of their family and to
teach him sign language.
As the family saga at the institute
unfolds, so does the 1929 story
of a schoolteacher whose
encounters with a white doctor
from the institute, painfully
illuminate both the past
and the present.
Released earlier this year to much
acclaim, Publishers Weekly described
"We Love You, Charlie Freeman," as
ambitious and deftly constructed,
encompassing weighty issues such
as race, language, sexuality,
and the intersections
of religion and science,
and calling it a sobering look at
how we communicate with one another
and what inevitably gets
lost in translation.
Greenidge was born in Boston,
and received her MFA
from Hunter College.
She's started writing the
novel during her first semester
of graduate school, during
which time she also worked
as a historical researcher
at a Black history museum.
Her writing has appeared in The
Believer, American Short Fiction,
The Feminist Wire, Afro-Pot
Magazine, The New York Times,
and many other publications.
And she has received fellowships
from the Lower Manhattan Community
Council's Workspace Program,
and the Bread Loaf
Writers Conference.
She is also a recent recipient
of a literature fellowship
from the National Endowment
for the Arts.
This is a highly competitive
fellowship based solely
on artistic excellence and selected
through an anonymous review process.
If you're interested in learning
more about these fellowships,
you can stop by our
table over there.
Please join me in welcoming
Kaitlyn Greenidge.
[ Applause ]
>> Kaitlyn Greenidge: Hi,
so I'm Kaitlyn Greenidge.
Thank you so much for coming today.
So I thought that I would first talk
a little bit about how the book came
to be, because that's usually
people's first question
when I tell them what
this book is about.
So I thought I'd talk a little bit
about that, and then I might read
from the first opening pages for
a little bit, and then open it
up to questions from you guys.
And we can kind of have a, hopefully
a group conversation in the room.
So, "We Love You, Charlie Freeman,"
as was very beautifully introduced,
is about a Black family from
Boston that moves to a nearly,
all white town in the
Berkshires in the early 1990s.
And they moved there to
take part in an experiment
where they're teaching sign
language to a chimpanzee.
So, that idea came
to me kind of as a
like thunderbolt or
a lightning bolt.
I was at a bar in Brooklyn that used
to have a lecture series
called "Adult Education."
And they would do like quirky
lecture subjects every Saturday.
And you would go and you would have
a drink and listen to these kind
of strange, interesting pieces
about history and the past.
And one time I went and then theme
for the night was "Animals
and Deviance."
And a woman gave a lecture about
this family named the Kelloggs.
Was a married pair of
anthropologists in the 1920s,
and they decided to do an experiment
where they raised their
son alongside a chimpanzee.
They wrote a book about it called,
"The Ape and the Child," that came
out towards the tail
end of the 1920s.
And you can still find this book.
I actually, as soon as I heard about
this, I went to Amazon and I tried
to find it and I got a copy of it.
The reason why you
can still find it is
because their studies
was really kind
of like universally
panned by everybody.
Everybody was kind of like,
"That is a crazy idea.
Why would you ever do
that to your child?"
kind of thing.
And if you look through
the book, it's fascinating.
They literally took their toddler
and then this young chimpanzee
and put them side by side
and took photographs of them.
And they do things like they shoot
off a revolver behind their heads
and see who reacted fastest, the
first, and take a photograph of it.
It just, all these really
interesting and wonderful images
and really frightening
images are within this book.
And so, when the Kelloggs
published the book in the 1920s,
most of the anthropology
community was horrified,
and so they quickly kind
of distanced themselves
from this subject.
And they gave the chimpanzee
actually back
to the research facility
where they got her from.
And then their son, when he
grew up many years later,
he actually committed suicide.
That was kind of like the
very sad coda to the story.
So, I'm sitting in the audience and
I'm about to go into grad school
for creative writing,
and I'm thinking, "Wow,
that's a really fascinating story.
That could probably be a really
great short story, and let me try
and make this into what
it could possibly be."
And at the same time, when
I was thinking about that,
about that story and kind of all
that stuff was just kind of going
through my brain, as was
said in the introduction,
I was working as a researcher for
a Black history museum in Brooklyn,
called the Weeksville
Heritage Center.
If you've never been, you
should definitely check it out.
It's in Crown Heights, Brooklyn.
It's been around since 1968.
Really fascinating museum.
Wonderful resource.
It's dedicated to the history of
the first free Black community
in Brooklyn that was
founded in 1827.
And it's been a continual
Black neighborhood
in that area too, till today.
So anyways, I was working
as a researcher there,
and I had been working probably at
that point for the past ten years
as a researcher, or some sort
of historical interpreter,
for Black history sites either
in New York City or in Boston.
And while I was doing that
work, a lot of the time,
of what I was doing, was
kind of talking directly
to people about Black history.
And for a little while, when I was
in Boston, I worked as a park ranger
for the Black Heritage Trail,
which meant that I was kind
of dressed like Smoky the Bear.
Like I had a park ranger
uniform on, the park ranger hat,
and I would stand in front of
the memorial to the 54th regiment
which was the first
all-Black regiment to fight
for the United States army.
They made the movie
Glory about them.
So I'd stand in front of this
memorial which is directly
across the street from the Boston
State House, for four to five hours
at a time, in the summertime,
talking to tourists just
walking by, about Black history.
And as you can imagine, those
conversations ranged and varied
and were really interesting and
sometimes really hard to have.
So you would have people -- our tour
started where the Freedom Trail,
which covers Boston's
Revolutionary War history ended.
So a lot of times, you'd have people
saying, "Where's the Freedom Trail?"
And you would say, "It's
not the Freedom Trail.
It's the Black History Trail.
You want to come on it?"
And then people would
kind of run away.
Or you would say like,
"Are you interested
in kind of talking about this?"
And people would want to argue
with you about the causes
of the Civil War or they'd want to
talk about the merits of slavery
or who started slavery first.
A lot of times, people wanted
to talk about really just --
really only certain
moments of Black history.
So, that particular site
that I worked at was talking
about Boston's Black
Abolitionists Movement which started
like basically at the same
time as the Revolutionary War.
But people would really only kind
of want to talk about this --
the Civil War for like these
four years of Black history.
If they didn't want to talk about
that then they wanted to talk
about the Civil Rights Movement.
So another kind of very brief
moment in Black history.
And you would -- I would say
to people like, "Oh this is --
but this other thing happened
and this person did
this really heroic act
and this really interesting
thing happened," or whatever.
And people would say, "Yes,
but let's get back to slavery.
Can you tell us again
about slavery?"
So, as I was in there and I'm kind
of standing there and if you work
with Black history, these are
kind of arguments that we kind
of always kind of come up
again, again and again,
when we talk about Black history.
It feels actually really fortuitous
that I'm here the same weekend
that the museum --
the National Museum
for African American History is
opening, which is so exciting
because all of a sudden, all of this
wonderful information is available
to us on a much bigger stage
and in a completely different
way than it has been before.
So it feels, for me, I mean I
think everybody's really excited
about that museum opening,
but for me,
it just feels like it's a turning
point I think in how we're going
to be able to process and think
about those things going forward.
So all of those things were circling
around my mind and I go and I sit
down and I try and figure out
what are all those things mean
and what do I actually want
to say about all those things?
And what are the conversations
that I wish
that we could have
about all those things?
And what are the conversations
that I wish
that we could have
about all those things?
And what are the questions
that I wish that we could ask
about all those things that
sometimes we either avoid asking
or we don't feel like
asking of ourselves?
And so that's kind of the
impetuous of the book,
where the book came from.
I really wanted to write and talk
about a Black experience
in the northeast.
So the book takes place
in Boston and in the --
in western Massachusetts
in the Berkshires region.
A lot of times, when people
talk about Black history
and Black identity, it's
really centered in the south,
and we know a little bit more
about southern Black experiences,
but of course, Black
identity isn't a monolith.
Black American identity
differs from region to region.
There's rich history
in all of the regions.
And so I got really interested
about that and especially
when I was doing more research and
I came across these photo studies
of -- well, photographs first that
I saw of integrated classrooms
in the Berkshires in the 1890s.
And Du Bois who of course
was a famous Black scholar,
he actually grew up in Western
Massachusetts in the Berkshires
and I thought, "Wow,
that's really fascinating.
That has to somehow address that
or talk about that in the book.
And then also finding out that
Du Bois himself did these really
interesting photographic studies
of Black people throughout
the United States,
in the 1890s and early 1900s.
And he made a big album
of them and presented it
at the Paris Exhibition
in the 1900s.
So it feels like there's all these
kind of themes and things that come
up again and again, kind of
undercurrents, in history,
that I kept getting more and
more interested of talking about
and thinking about and trying
to work into a narrative.
If you can't tell by now, my
training is to be a researcher.
I'm not really a natural
storyteller.
I love finding interesting and
wonderful facts that are hidden
in archives and other places,
and bringing them up and trying
to get people to talk about them.
So, getting all of those
interesting bits of information
into an actual narrative,
was really difficult
and took a really long time.
So I started this book in fall 2008,
and it was published
in March of this year.
So it took a really long
time to figure out how
to dramatize those things and
make them into a book that --
in a story that feels natural
and that you will kind
of want to follow along.
And I think like probably everybody
who's at this book festival,
I love novels and I love books, but
for a long time of those eight years
and before that as well, it felt
like a huge kind of leap to be able
to get to the point of putting
all those things that I love
and that I'm interested in, into
an actual novel that's going
to be readable by somebody else
besides my family, you know?
So, a lot of that time was
spent doing a lot of research
on additional parts of the book
that really kind of interested me.
As soon as I knew that I
wanted the family to be fluent
in sign language, I started to
research a lot about that aspect
and way of communication,
the history of sign language.
I should stop here to say that
I always talk about this book
as if the idea came from
like a really outside source,
and part of it did, but while I
was doing the research in this book
and starting to write
about this book,
I remember that there
is this family story.
So my mother knows sign language.
She's been fascinated with that
language from a really young age.
And she, for a little while,
when they lived in this area,
she actually went to
Gallaudet College
for a little while in the 1970s.
And when she and my father were
living in New York in the 1970s,
she was taking sign language
classes at Hunter College
and she actually got asked
to -- if she would --
to apply for a job at a research
institute in West Chester
where they did have
chimpanzees and they asked her
if she would be interested in kind
of working really closely
with that chimpanzee.
And when they found out that
she had a daughter, a toddler,
they got super excited and
wanted her to work with it.
And the story in my family
was always that it was kind
of like a throw away story.
My mom is a really fascinating
person and has millions of stories
like that where she'll just
kind of drop it in conversation.
And we'll be like, "What
are you talking about?
[Inaudible]."
But the story with that is that
she thought about it and was kind
of horrified with this idea of
bonding with another animal,
and then having to give them
up at the end of the study.
And especially of her child doing
that and having to give it up.
So she said, "Absolutely not,
no, I would never do this."
And the joke in our family was
always that my dad was really upset
about it because we would
have gotten a free car
and a free house in West Chester.
And he's like, "We've could
have saved a lot of money
for the year," so we
lived in New York.
So, I knew a little bit
about sign language.
My mom used sign language
around the house.
When I went to work with
her, when she was --
she worked for many years at Perkins
School for the Blind in Boston,
and while she was there, she worked
with a program with autistic adults
and adults without much
access to language.
So she actually used sign language
a lot there and I would to work
with her and I would
see her use it a lot.
And so I knew a little
bit about the language.
I don't actually know how to use
it myself, but she still does.
But as I was doing
more research about it,
I found out that there was a
dialect of American sign language,
African American sign language,
that history of that language
was really fascinating.
And that that the signs
are different
and that the reason why
they're different is actually
because you know, if you
know anything about history
of deaf Americans or deaf liberation
movements in this country,
for a long time sign language was
not allowed in many deaf schools
because people thought that
it was encouraging deaf people
to stay amongst themselves.
And so there's this whole
really interesting history
around the identity around that.
All that is to say that
many schools for the deaf
for Black children
never had that ban.
So a whole other kind of version
of the language spread up --
spread and grew and that whole
history was really interesting to me
and something that I tried to bring
out and to talk about in the book.
Because for me, the book is really
a lot about the limits of language,
the limits of language
that we have even
when we have the best intentions for
the words that we're trying to use.
And how much people use language,
both to explain really uncomfortable
and really hurtful situations,
and also to try and mask
or minimize those situations.
And I was at a class in Amherst on
Wednesday, I was talking to a class
at Amherst and [inaudible],
one of the students said, "Oh,
this book has a lot
of silences in it.
There's a lot of moments where the
characters either don't say things
to each other that they should say,
or they're just not able to finish
or get back to a conversation."
And that's kind of how I
experienced language a lot
when I was writing this book
and even before I started
writing this book.
You know, somebody who reads and
loves books and loves writing,
there's still always felt like
there was some sort of limitation,
that sometimes it seemed like the
books that I was so interested
in engaging with, only went so far
and that there were still
other questions to keep going
and that I wanted answered.
And for a long time, I think and
when I was probably a teenager,
I was really mournful
about that and I got kind
of like, "Well what can books do?
Kind of where we got stuck here,
where can they kind of go?"
And now as an adult and after
reading a little bit more
and talking to writers
more, I realize that a lot
of times writers themselves
when they write books are
aware of those limitations.
And that's actually kind of the
thing that keeps writing alive
and keeps writing going is that
you read a book and you realize
that it opens you up
hopefully to 10, or 11, or 12,
or hundreds of more questions.
And that your reading can
actually lead you kind
of further and further.
And that sense of kind
of never completion,
kind of language always -- just
getting there but like not enough,
actually became a real strength for
me when I was thinking about writing
and thinking about books.
And so now I get really
excited when I --
and when I read a book
and I close it
and there's more questions
than I have answers.
I always think of that James
Baldwin quote, which I'm going
to totally butcher because
I did not write it down
but I think it's something like,
"Art is there to ask questions,
not answer them for us."
So, that became really interesting
and really important to me
for this project, for this
book as I was writing it was
that hopefully this book is a
conversation with the reader.
And hopefully this is
something where you read it
and you can have additional
questions
or ask people additional questions.
There's -- I don't know if anyone
of you have seen Junot Diaz speak,
but he often tells a story when he
does his speeches where he's talking
about if he's teaching a complicated
text, when he used to teach
at a commuter college and he
was teaching a complicated text
and he would ask the class,
"Does anybody understand
this -- what we just read?"
Everybody would feel comfortable
raising their hand and saying,
"No, I didn't understand."
And they would have
a class discussion.
That would be class.
And then he said that when he
got to starting to teach at MIT,
they would -- he would bring a
complicated text and he would say,
"Does anybody understand
what we just read?"
and everybody would say "Yes."
And then he'd say, "Okay,
can anybody explain it?"
And the room would go silent.
And the conversation was
over because nobody wanted
to admit what they didn't know
or where the limits of
their knowledge were.
And he talks also a lot
about kind of the importance
of books having that ambiguity.
How for him when he was a kid
and he was reading a book,
when he came across a word that
he didn't know, he would assume
that the writer had put that word
there so that you were supposed
to close the book and go
ask somebody about it.
And that was a chance for you to
have a conversation with somebody
about a word that you didn't know
and that's how you're
supposed to learn it.
So, both of those kind of
ideas were really profound
and really interesting to me.
And really drive kind of the
way that this book came to be
and how I hope this book
exists in the world.
I got really worried about,
when I was writing this book,
about halfway through because
there's so many elements in it
that are strange or
like almost grotesque
because I like the grotesque.
I mean, I think that's
pretty obvious.
I'm not going to hide it.
But I like those sorts of
things but I got really worried
when I was writing it about halfway
through about whether this
book would find an audience
or who the audience would be for it.
But I think keeping that in mind
that books that are kind of --
that the purpose of books are to
be kind of thorny and to engage
with you and to trouble you a
little bit and to trouble a reader,
where things have kind
of kept me going.
And those are the kind of books that
I turn to or that I turn to again
and again and get really
excited about.
So, the book went through a couple
of different revisions and back
and forths and a lot of
the research as well,
I realized at a certain point
that I wanted part of the book
to take place in 1920s
Belgian Congo.
And so that took a whole bunch of
research and thinking and writing
and talking about things.
And I realized also at a certain
point that I was going to have
to do a little bit more research
around what exactly it would be
like to live with a chimpanzee.
I should say, before --
at this point, that I'm not really a
huge fan of animals, so I wasn't --
that part of writing about
this was not the thing
that interested me the most.
The thing that interested
me the most was kind
of larger discussions
about race and language.
But at a certain point, I was
like, "I have to just buckle down
and start thinking about
what exactly it means
to be a chimpanzee."
And that part of the research
went for a short period of time
and then it was like, "Let me use
my imagination a little bit more
to kind of think about this,
about how these elements
will all interact."
A big part of this, of
working on this book,
and what took so long also
was realizing when to kind
of stop my research and kind
of let storytelling take over.
So a really big and comforting
piece of information or anecdote
that really helped was I'm a
huge fan of Edward P. Jones.
And when he was writing
"The Known World," he talked
about when you stop research and
when you keep going with research.
And that you could spend
all day sitting around,
researching the exact type of
saddle that would have been used
in 18-whenever in the county
that he's trying to write
about and that he's making up.
Or at a certain point you could
realize that for the reader,
it's just a saddle, and
for the actual character
in the scene, it's just a saddle.
And when we think about the things
that we use every day in our life,
oftentimes we don't necessarily
think of all those kind
of wealth of research and details.
So, it's a fine balance I think for
writers for people who love books
about where you put all of
that information and all
of that really kind
of fine detailed eye.
And a lot of writing the book was
trying to figure out those pieces
of the book and trying to figure
out those things about it.
So, I'm going to take a
break from kind of talking
about how the book came to be.
I'm going to read from the
opening pages of the book.
I should say that the book switches
perspectives so, the book --
parts of the book are
told by Charlotte,
who's the oldest daughter
in the family.
And then other parts of the
book explore how her family,
her mother Laurel, her father
Charles, and her sister Callie,
are experiencing the experiment.
And then two other sections
of the book are told
from characters in the 1920s.
One of a woman named Nymphadora
who lives in the town that is --
has this institute that's
running the experiment,
and the other is Julia Toneybee
Leroy [phonetic] who's a rubber
heiress and she's actually the
impetuous for the experiment.
She's given the money
to this institute
and it's the one who's the driving
force behind this experiment.
So, I'm going to start with
reading from Charlotte's section,
and then I'll read a little
bit of the Nymphadora section.
And then I think I'll
open to questions
if anybody has any questions.
Charlotte.
"This car doesn't feel
like ours," I said.
"Well, it is now," my father said
with a sigh, "So get used to it."
Outside of the car
it was dark and hot
and early morning August
in Dorchester.
Through the crack of the window, I
could smell every part of the city,
every slab of asphalt, every
rotting plank of wood siding,
every crumbling stucco wall,
every scarred and skinny tree.
I could smell all of
it beginning to sweat.
I sat back in my seat.
I knew I was right.
Our old car was a used silver
Chevy sedan, a dubious gift
from my uncle Lyle, a mechanic.
The Chevy's backseats were
balding, the foam cushions peeling
with faded stickers from some
long discarded coloring book.
The Chevy's body slumped over
its axis, slung way too low
to the ground, so that when
you opened the car's doors,
their bottoms scraped the curb.
The new car was a 1991 silver Volvo
station wagon, next year's model.
The Toneybee Institute paid for it.
It had a curt, upturned nose
that looked smug and out
of place beside the lazing sedans
and subservient hatchbacks
parked on our block.
Being inside the Volvo felt
like we were in public.
None of us could bring
ourselves to speak.
We were all too humbled
by the leather interiors.
My mother, in the driver's seat,
adjusted her rearview mirror.
My younger sister, Callie, kept
playing with the automatic windows
until my mother told her to stop.
Up in the front seat, my father
tugged on his gers one by one,
trying to crack his knuckles,
but the cartilage wouldn't break.
I shifted my legs, and the leather
skin of the seat stuck to the backs
of my thighs, made a slow,
painful smack as I leaned forward.
"They know we're no good
with animals, right?"
I moved again and the
leather creaked beneath me.
"I mean, you told them that?"
"What are you talking about?"
My mother rolled down her window,
began to fuss with the
driver's side mirror.
"We're great with animals."
"We are not.
We're terrible with pets."
"Well, that's e because
we won't have a pet."
My mother had been
saying this for weeks.
"Charlie isn't a pet."
"He's a research monkey,"
my father added.
"He's a chimpanzee."
This was my sister, Callie.
"He's more than a pet,"
my mother corrected.
"He's going to be like
a brother to you."
My father said, "That's
going a bit far, Laurel."
"What I'm trying to say," she
began, "is that we just have
to treat him like one of us.
Like he's part of our family.
We just have to make
him feel like he's one
of our own and he'll do e."
"But all our pets die."
"Charlotte."
My mother was scanning
the street now.
"It's true.
That rabbit you bought me when I
was e and Callie was born."
"He was depressed."
My father turned in his seat.
"It was because we kept him
under the kitchen counter."
My father had a notebook open in his
lap, the pages turned to the start
of a geometry lesson plan, but
he hadn't written anything yet.
Over his shoulder, I could
see where he'd drawn a grove
of interlocking pineapples
in the sheet's margins.
"In our defense," my mother
said, "we had to keep him there.
We just didn't have the space."
She tugged at her side mirror again.
She frowned, made an appreciative
"ah," and rolled her window back up.
She touched a button
on the dashboard,
and the mirror gave a delicate
little shudder and began
to angle itself toward her.
She glanced over at
my father, grinned.
"Very nice," he said.
I stuck my head in the
space between them.
"That rabbit died because
he ate his own fur.
He choked on it.
He died because he
choked on himself."
"Is that true?"
Callie strained against
her seat belt,
trying to catch what we were saying.
"No." My mother swatted at me.
"Charlotte, get back there,
get back in your seat.
Put your seat belt on.
You're upsetting your sister."
We didn't even have seat
belts in the old car.
I ran mine across my chest,
clicked the buckle closed.
I waited. Then I said,
"Dad's h."
My mother shot me a warning
glance in the rearview mirror.
"Dad was in charge of the
h and it still died."
No one answered me.
After a while I said,
"And it didn't even die.
It just kind of ked away."
"I think I'm going to
be sick," Callie moaned.
"He had mange."
My father turned again in his
seat, trying to catch Callie's eye.
"I've told you this before.
He already had it when we brought
him home from the pet store."
But I persisted.
"Mom had to take that h out of
the tank and put him in a paper bag
and bury him at the park
because he was so messed
up he would have polluted
our toilets.
We made a h too
sick for a toilet, Mom."
"I'm going to be sick,"
Callie declared.
"Charlotte, no talking."
My mother leaned forward
and switched on the radio
and a too deep voice
intoned, "W-I-L-D Boston."
That station was at the
top of the list of things
that my mother forbade us.
"Nothing but booty music," she'd
say, a di-missal that made me
and Callie squirm in embarrassment.
Now, though, she turned the
volume up until the sound buzzed
over us, drowning out our words.
My last piece of evidence I signed
to Callie underneath the
stutter of a drum machine.
The mice, I explained with my hands.
We had mice and they died of heart
attacks because they mated too much.
They fucked, and here I spelled it
out because I didn't know the sign
for that yet, they
f-u-c-k-e-d to death.
How did they do that?
Callie signed back.
I shook my head and turned
my face to the window.
Okay, so that's Callie's section.
[ Applause ]
And then I'll read from
Nymphadora's section.
So she is a -- she's living
in the Berkshires in 1929.
And I think that's
all you need to know.
I think it will become
pretty clear as we go on.
My mother was a Star of a Morning.
My father was a sadder night.
I was first an infant of delivery
star, and then I was a girl star,
then a young lady star, and three
years ago, right before mama
and pop drank a jigger of cyanide
each, I became in my own right,
a full-blown star of the
morning, Fifth House,
Second Quadrant Division,
northeastern launch
of the colored hamlet of
Spring City in the town
of Cortland County, Massachusetts.
After my parents committed suicide,
I declared, if only to myself,
that I was no longer
a Star of the Morning.
But even now, three years on,
I can't stop wearing my pin.
During the day, while
I'm teaching class,
it's hidden under my shirt
collar, pinned right up close
to the front of my throat.
At night, after I've dressed
my hair and put it in its cap
after I've rubbed my face
first with cold cream
and then a worn oily piece of
chamois, I do what mama showed me.
I stand in front of the mirror,
my skin all greasy and soft,
and take off the pin while
staring at my reflection.
A star of the morning is never
allowed to look directly at her pin.
My pin is a small, brass knot, filed
down to look like a burst of light,
with a rusty garnet in the middle.
When I was an infant star, I would
stand in the mirror beside mama,
watching our reflections' fingers
at work unfastening our pins,
and I was filled with love.
I thought it was the most
beautiful thing in the world.
Mama told me it was
better than a diamond.
Stars of the Morning always take
off their pins before they sleep,
and always before their
evening prayers so as not
to make a false idol out of it.
Now, when I take off my pin, I
place it on my nightstand and then,
if I was to follow what mama
taught me, I am supposed to reflect
on my moral failings during the
day, and recite the Lord's Prayer,
because Stars of the Morning are
good Christian [inaudible] women.
But no one, if they could read my
thoughts would call me a Christian
anymore, and besides, I
don't believe in prayer.
So during this bit of the routine,
I try to just sit quiet on my bed.
But after years of ritual,
I can't help myself.
Even when I'm dumb, the blood
in my ears pounds out the rhythm
of "Our Father, who art in heaven."
To drown out these pious
cadences, in my head,
I sometimes chant the obscene
version I learned as girl.
"Our Father, who farts in heaven,
Horesch [phonetic] be his name."
I am a 36-year-old, unmarried,
orphaned, negro school teacher,
in charge of a roomful of
impressionable young colored minds,
and every night, I sing a dirty,
nursery rhyme to help
me go to sleep.
It is enough to laugh if I did
not always feel like weeping.
The time for prayer
over, ready for bed,
the last thing I do before I
lay down and blow out the light,
is to stand before the mirror
again, and pinch the pin
between my fingers, and
very carefully stick it
to the lace collar of nightgown.
I've slept with the pin for
as long as I can remember.
At the base of my neck, just
below the collarbone, is a livid,
red line from its sharpest
end, drawing on me.
My best memory is of initiation.
I was 7 years old.
We stood in front of the
church basement door,
on a lawn so bright you could
see the green even in dusk.
My mother was the most powerful star
in Spring City, so I was the head
of the line, even though
I didn't want to be.
I was terrified.
An older girl had once told me
that to become an infant star,
they set your hair on fire.
Her friends said the big women stars
made you shake a dead lady's hand,
the hand of the very
first star who ever lived.
"The big women stars keep it
in a special box," she said,
"and when you shake
it, the bones crunch
and the dust gets on your fingers.
The dead lady's dust is
what makes you a star."
I had asked mama about
all of these rumors
and she told me they were nonsense,
and those girls were just jealous.
Their mothers were loose women
and the girls had proven
themselves unruly.
And so they could never
become an infant star like me.
But I remained uneasy
and when I pressed mama,
she still wouldn't tell me exactly
what happened at initiation.
All my life, I thought we
had no secrets between us.
The year before when our tabby Dina,
birthed a litter, she told me frank
and shrew how cats
and people were made.
She told me how the universe came to
be, and where our earth stood in it.
And that God did not live in the
sun, but in the breath and air
and dust around and within us.
"The sun is just a very bright
ball," she told me, which was more
than the other mothers
told their children.
But she wouldn't tell me
about becoming a star,
as many times as I asked her.
For initiation, I wore
a white lace dress
and patent leather shoes mama
ordered special from Boston.
Nine little girls pressed against
my back all breathing heavy.
We had to fast for a day and
a night before initiation.
According to the bylaws of
the Stars of the Morning,
infant stars are supposed to
consume only milk and honey,
and they have to chant,
"I'm a vessel for the light
of our Lord," before they drink it.
But no one in Spring City could
afford honey, so we drank our milk
with raw brown sugar instead.
I breathed the rotten sweetness
of it on the other children's spit
and in their girlish sweat.
I squeezed my eyes shut very
tight and kept them that way
until I heard the basement
door of the church rumble open.
I heard the girls behind me
breath quicker, talk faster.
I felt something brushing
against my hand.
"The dead woman," I thought, but
the hand that took mine was fat
and warm, and it led me very
carefully down the steps
and into the church basement.
Once I was there, it smelled the
same as it always had, like earth
and the moths that ate the choir
robes, and the greening tint
of the church collection plate.
I almost opened my
eyes, but a voice said,
"Keep your lights closed,
infant star."
Right beneath my chin, I felt
a point of warmth and I knew
that it was someone holding
a candle close to my face.
This comforted me somehow
to know the light was near.
I heard the other girls stumble down
the stairs, one by one, most gasped,
a few of the very young
ones started to cry.
Then I heard the basement
door rumble shut.
I opened my eyes and I laughed.
I laughed because even though
the room smelled just the same,
when I opened my eyes, I saw it had
become the most beautiful place I
have ever been in my
life before or since.
It wasn't dark.
The earth walls were
covered in white paper.
What seemed like a thousand
candles were lit all around us,
in tiny glass and tin lanterns.
Strings of white hydrangea were
threaded across the top of the room.
Clouds hung down from the ceiling
and for a moment I thought,
"Mama's brought down the
very sky to greet me."
But then I saw that it was just
tool from Ms. Vera's dress shop,
double up on itself
to seem like heaven.
We jumbled ourselves all up
until we formed a new line.
I was now in the middle.
Mama strode up before us in a long,
white robe, trimmed with yellow.
She held a gold bound
Bible in her hands.
She opened a page at random and one
by one, we had to hover a finger
over the Bible, let it fall down,
and then read from
whichever passage we chose.
The passage gave us our secret name;
the name only other
stars knew us by.
The poor girl before me chose
Herod, and she cried and cried
because she was going to have to go
by the name of a known baby killer.
I thought for certain mama would let
her pick again, but she only looked
on sternly as another star
patted the little girl's back,
and told her some quickly
made up nonsense
about this being a
splendid opportunity
to restore honor to the name.
I was relieved then when
I picked Nymphadora.
My real name is Ellen, but
Nymphadora is so much better.
I bet you didn't know there
was a Nymphadora in the Bible.
There is, Colossians 4:15.
Later, I found out our
Bible was a mistranslation.
It should have read Nympha, and
Nympha should have been a man.
It was by some lucky magic that I
got so fine a name as Nymphadora
of the Spring City Stars.
Nymphadora sounded beautiful
and elegant and pretty and peek.
I liked that the Nymphadora in our
Bible ran a church in her own home.
I was proud of the name but
when I turned a threw a smile
at mama, she did not return it.
When we were all newly
named, mama inspected the ten
of us and still did not speak.
She raised her hand and Ms.
Vera and another Star rolled
out a tea table stacked with
food, real food, bowls of potatoes
and biscuits and a lanky turkey
with its bony ankles wrapped
in paper to keep its marrow warm.
Our deflated stomachs milk lined
in sugary, leapt in revolt,
but mama wouldn't let us eat.
Instead, she stood in
front of the table.
"Girls," she said, "you
are almost infant stars.
Do you know what makes
a star shine?"
No one answered.
We were all watching the spread
behind her, too hungry to speak.
"Girls," she said, "I've
asked you a question.
A tenet of being an infant star is
to speak when you are spoken to.
So we will begin again.
What makes a star shine?"
The newly named Herod
sniffed loudly, wiped the snot
from her face, "The
light of heaven?"
she offered cautiously?
It was a good guess, as we'd had
to drone this phrase incessantly
for the past few days as we fasted.
"No," mama said.
"No, not the light of heaven.
What makes a Star of
the Morning shine,
what makes an infant star shine
among all the other pieces of dust
and dirt and rock that
are our Lord's creations,
is self-control, denial.
Denial built up inside
little infant stars like you,
makes your moral fiber
strong like flint,
so that when the world tests you,
when the world rubs up against you,
all vicious and sharp,
and everything within you,
everything is telling you to give
in, all your desire is to give in,
do you know what happens?
You don't give in.
You don't become soft.
You ignore your desires.
The world's trials stir up light
in you so strong, so pure, so true,
no man on earth could put it out.
Denial of your desires is what
makes an infant star shine."
Mama leaned up against the table
and crossed her arms over her chest.
She lifted her chin up to the
paper clouds and began to declaim.
And even though she was my mother
and even though I worshipped her,
I wanted to groan because I was a
smart little star, and I could read
between the lines and see
despite the turkey's paper socks,
promising meat kept
warm, we weren't going
to be eating anything, anytime soon.
And when we finally did, it
would most certainly be cold.
The very first star
denied herself everything
so that she could be a
beacon of light for others.
Her name was Mary Whitman
and she was a slave.
Herod gasped at this.
We were negroes it was true, but
we were all northern negroes,
born of at least two
generations of freed men.
Those with slavery closer to
them than that, kept it hidden.
The first Emancipation Day
was nearly 40 years past.
Slaves were the Israelites
in the Bible.
They were the figures drawn in
quick blurry clouds of black ink
in the illustrated editions
of "Uncle Tom's Cabin"
we read in school.
Though we understood that some of
us were once them, and that we had
to bake cakes every
church bazaar for those
who were still pretty much them,
it never occurred to us as children
that slaves could live
in Spring City,
Massachusetts any more
than camels could.
"Yes," mama said, "she was
a slave and she ran away
and came here to the north.
But in order to run, she had
to deny herself everything.
She had to deny herself love.
She had a mother and father
and husband and little babies
and she had to leave them behind.
She had to deny herself love
and she ran and she ran,
and when she came here, when she
came to the north, she was so full
of light from her trials
that she became a star.
And she began this sisterhood to
teach other negro women how to shine
like her, because in order for the
negro race to survive and thrive,
we need a hundred stars,
a thousand stars,
full of light to show
others the way."
Mama rested against the table
and I heard the wood groan,
and just a whiff, just
the tiniest hint
of melted butter filled the air.
"Not everyone can be a
star," she continued.
"Not everyone can be so
strong as to deny themselves
to make sure the negro
race survives.
But we believe you infant
stars have the potential
to become Stars of the Morning."
And here, mama gestured to Ms. Dora
who brought her a wooden backed
chair, which mama sat down on,
arranged her skirts,
made herself comfortable.
And I cannot remember the rest
of the speech from the night,
because my attention was taken
up with keeping my lips pressed
together and sucking hard
on my own tongue to
keep from standing up,
pushing my own mother aside,
and lapping up the mounds
of potatoes stacked behind her.
Okay, that's the end
of that section.
[ Applause ]
That was a longer one,
so thank you guys
for indulging me while
I read that one.
And now I'll open up to questions
if you guys want to ask questions.
Oh, great.
>> My great aunt, who
raised my mother in part,
was a teacher of the
deaf in Northampton.
>> Kaitlyn Greenidge:
Oh wow, wonderful.
>> And the Clarke School there had
that oralist tradition
you were talking
about that ASL was
discouraged and was matter
in some ways I guess you
know, well-motivated to fit
in to the rest of society.
>> Kaitlyn Greenidge: Right.
>> Partly the desire of parents to
make sure their kids didn't stand
out or weren't set apart.
But I wonder, you know, in
the larger arc of your book
or your own life, this notion to fit
in, to assimilate, to be the same,
you know, what is that
dynamic tension?
How do you resolve that?
>> Kaitlyn Greenidge:
That's a great question.
Thank you.
So, the book in part was about
that -- is about that question.
Is about what do you
sacrifice when you try
to make this way for assimilation?
And you know, America likes to
constantly talk about ourselves,
but we are a really interesting
and fascinating nation that we made
up of people from all over.
And that is the tension in
question built into our very fiber
of our being of this country.
And I mean, we fight
about it constantly.
I mean it's at the heart of
probably every kind of major issue
that we talk about, is
what do you kind of give
up to become a part of the whole?
And what are the benefits of
being a part of the whole?
And can we mourn and can we
acknowledge the things that we lose
when we try to kind of
become a part of a whole?
And so, those are -- I don't think
those questions are easily answered.
I mean, I don't think
anybody has a one sentence
or a three sentence
answer to those questions,
but I do think they're really
interesting to keep asking
about these processes that we
do because on the one hand,
there is the practical need for
a group to assimilate for you
to be able to work together in some
kind of way, but on the other hand,
there is so much lost
and there's so much given
up by the group being asked to
assimilate that is not asked
of the group that they're
supposed to be assimilating into.
And so, I think that
tension, for actually I think
where what I find really interesting
about it is when people try to deny
that that tension exists
for certain things and say
that it's either all one
way or all the other.
I don't think it's ever either
all one way or all the other
for that question around
assimilation.
I think that tension
is kind of constant.
And people can come up with
different answers and different ways
of how they're going
to try and figure out.
And I think each generation of
people comes up with their own way
of explaining what that's
supposed to be for themselves.
And a lot of that also comes
from looking at the past,
looking at parents and grandparents,
and what they've had to sacrifice
or give up, and as a descendent
saying, "Was it really worth it?"
So.
>> I'll talk to you offline
about this, but Du Bois,
I did my senior thesis and I think
he had a lot of thoughts on that.
>> Kaitlyn Greenidge: Oh, of course.
Yes, yes, yes.
Great. Any other questions?
Oh, wrap up.
Over allotted time.
Okay, sorry.
You were sitting right
there the whole time.
I was like looking for you in the
audience, but you were right there.
Okay. Apologies that that went
longer, but thank you so much
and hopefully can talk
to some of you off stage.
So thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at www.Loc.gov.